bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoints
l'émission qui revient sur l'actualité
économique locale une émission
exceptionnellement réduite à 13 minutes
pendant les vacances scolaires et on
commence tout de suite avec les
informations de la semaine les travaux
autour de la gare de Saint-Quentin
prennent fin la place Joël l'hôtel a été
rénovée la diagonale fait également peau
neuve peau neuve pardon mais les
chantiers ont pris un peu de retard un
aménagement qui n'a pas été sans
conséquence pour les commerces du coin
notamment pour les nouveaux arrivants
comme la socosité de courtage en
financement smdp financement des images
dès le Diwan
depuis fin 2013 le quartier de la gare
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines est en
chantier un projet de réhabilitation qui
a malheureusement gêné l'accès aux
différents commerces de la diagonale
parmi eux une société de courtage en
prêt immobilier fraîchement implanté à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux smdp financement
c'était vraiment un chemin un parcours
du combattant pour savoir où on était
alors c'est pas une critique c'est un
constat et ça ça ne nous a pas aidé
alors qu'on ne le savais pas on savait
qu'il y avait des travaux on ne savait
pas quelle ampleur de travaux on allait
rencontrer les retards sur le calendrier
du chantier n'ont évidemment rien
arrangé la jeune entreprise espère donc
lancer réellement son activité avec
l'arrivée des beaux jours partenaires de
la centrale de financement l'agence
aiguille particulier et entreprise pour
obtenir les meilleures conditions de
financement de leurs prêts immobiliers
elle propose également le rachat de
crédit ou de fonds à des taux plus bas
donc le but nous c'est de lui faire
gagner du temps et bien sûr de l'argent
parce que derrière on va se substituer à
lui pour aller négocier auprès des
fort de notre expérience de notre
professionnalisme du sérieux qu'on veut
mettre de la déontologie qu'on a
derrière les travaux de la diagonale
n'ont pas impacté que les jeunes
entreprises à quelques pas de là ce
salon de coiffure a vu sa clientèle de
passage diminué de 25%. si les habitués
sont restés de clients fidèles le
chiffre d'affaires a chuté surtout sur
des gros mots comme des cendres qui sont
des groupes au mois pour nous ouais on a
senti la différence par rapport à
l'année dernière on a eu une baisse de
5% 5% de baisse de chiffre d'affaires un
impact limité grâce à un gros effort de
communication et des offres
promotionnelles les travaux se terminent
pour vaner sa vie soir ne ses voisins
les affaires devraient reprendre
le premier forum de la création et de la
reprise d'entreprise s'est tenu
aujourd'hui dans la galerie marchande de
plaisir un lieu assez atypique pour
toucher le plus large public car des
opportunités existent bel et bien dans
l'entrepreneuriat Véronique et guerlon
adjointe au maire nous en dit un peu
plus
les acteurs économiques qui soient chef
d'entreprise aujourd'hui aux futurs
chefs d'entreprise ont besoin d'un
accompagnement tout particulier tant
dans la réflexion de la viabilité et
c'est la raison pour laquelle que nous
avons convié aujourd'hui service d'huile
avec la Maison de l'Entreprise centre
sud-yvelines nos partenaires donc dans
plusieurs secteurs expert-comptables
bancaires la Fédération des
auto-entrepreneurs d'autres voilà des
partenaires avec qui nous travaillons
ensemble et qui pourrons apporter dès le
départ et de manière regroupée le
conseil auprès de des acteurs
économiques
en termes de création d'entreprise le
taux de réussite reste de 50% pour
mettre toutes les chances de son côté il
faut être accompagné Nadine Lobin que
l'on peut voir sur ces images est
auto-entrepreneur depuis quatre ans dans
le milieu informatique elle cherche
aujourd'hui à changer de statut et à
sortir de son isolement professionnel
j'espère trouver ici des informations
que dans un premier temps j'ai
complètement élu des en faisant mon
entreprise dans mon coin toute seule et
j'ai d'ailleurs découvert la maison de
lampe que la Maison de l'emploi de
plaisir pouvait fournir de l'aide dans
moins d'un mois environ 750 salariés du
groupe Mercedes Benz France prendront
possession de leur nouveau locaux
auparavant installé à roconcourt le
groupe des ménages dans Saint-Quentin on
Yvelines et s'installe dans le quartier
du pas du lac à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
pour faire un premier pas versé futur
voisin la société a aujourd'hui remis un
don de 5000 euros à la PEI une
association unie Montaine qui vient en
aide aux enfants handicapés le
déménagement devrait se terminer aux
alentours du 18 juin on écoute les
explications du président du groupe
là pour le moment nous rassemblons tous
les collaborateurs de trois différents
sites autour de la région parisienne ici
à Montigny ça va nous changer la vie
parce que aujourd'hui nous partons de
différents bureaux individuels nous
aurons un grand espace là-bas sur ces
différents étages avec plusieurs
disciplines qui vont se rencontrer pour
la première fois depuis on va dire une
vingtaine d'années et on reste dans
l'automobile une marque allemande a
choisi les Yvelines pour s'installer
pour installer son plus grand terminal
de réparation et de vente cela se passe
à Vélizy il s'agit du terminal Audi 4800
m² dédiés à la réparation des véhicules
à la présentation des derniers modèles
et à la vente actuellement 46 salariés
sont employés dans ce terminal d'ici un
an à un an et demi il devait être il
devrait être 65 l'installation à Vélizy
n'est pas le fruit du hasard comme vous
allez l'entendre
les terrains sont un petit peu compliqué
à trouver une ligne de France
nos confrères mais concurrents avaient
trouvé des terrains et on construit des
grosses concessions derrière nous
l'autoroute A86 permet un passage de 100
000 véhicules par jour donc une très
grosse visibilité pour le constructeur
le site de Thalès à Élancourt vendredi
dernier ses portes à des lycéens
l'occasion pour nous de découvrir les
activités de la branche Thalès et
système aéroportés et l'emploi de 1900
personnes dont 1000 ici à Saint-Quentin
ces fonctions principales produire des
radars de pointe avant pour des avions
de type phrase ou bien de protéger les
avions des radars au sol cette fois le
responsable 19e nous explique les
profils des salariés de cette société
les métiers que l'on recherche couvrent
la conception de puces électroniques
très très complexe en fait il y a
également de ce qu'on appelle des
ingénieurs de système embarqué donc les
systèmes embarqués c'est des systèmes
qui
permettent de programmer des PC mais
c'est des PC un peu particuliers qui
sont sur des avions des fessées qui
doivent être très fiables et donc on
sait ce que l'on appelle le système
embarqué et on est obligé de maintenir
ce que l'on appelle le temps réel c'est
à dire que nous les informations que
l'on détecte ou que l'on reçoit on doit
les transmettre en temps réel et il ne
faut pas qu'il y ait de latence de
choses comme ça donc c'est des profils
également d'ingénieur système
d'architectes système et de personnes
qui sont impliquées dans les métiers de
la modélisation en fait puisque tous nos
censeurs aujourd'hui sont modélisés
comme si vous voulez dans le domaine
virtuel comme ce que l'on peut voir sur
les jeux vidéo parce que avant de les
concevoir on les conçoit de manière
numérique on les évalue de manière
numérique et on les présente à nos
clients d'abord de manière numérique
avant de les réaliser puisque forcément
ils sont très complexes très coûteux à
réaliser et ça prend beaucoup de temps
pour les réaliser
cette semaine nous retrouvons notre
invité non pas sur notre plateau mais
dans son entreprise il s'agit d'Hélène
Colas elle tient une chocolaterie qui a
intégré les codes du design dans ses
productions créer il y a 40 ans à
l'emploi aujourd'hui 22 personnes
visites guidées et découvertes du design
Colin culinaire dans ce dossier réalisé
avec Patrick Jacques dédiction et
Jonathan Willmann
pas qu'approche à grands pas et qui dit
pas qu'il y a des chocolats je vous
propose donc de découvrir une
chocolaterie pas comme les autres la
chocolaterie Colas à molle Hélène Colas
la Gironde fête cette année les 40 ans
de l'enseigne pour cet anniversaire une
rétrospective présente toutes les
collections confectionnées pour Pâques
au fil des années saveur aussi de voir
l'évolution finalement de la
chocolaterie qu'elle a pris de l'ampleur
en 40 ans voilà alors là on retrouve les
premières créations en fait ce que
faisait papa au tout début qui était
très traditionnel qui était vraiment
dans ce l'esthétique des pâtissiers des
années
70-80 et puis ensuite on voit que petit
à petit on s'éloigne de cette esthétique
un petit peu rétro et académique et puis
arrive la couleur arrive des montages
sur des thématiques plus plus
développées les parents d'Hélène ont
lancé une chocolaterie assez classique
en 1974 à l'époque il confectionnait
leur chocolat dans le sous-sol de leur
maison depuis la chocolaterie beaucoup
modernisé car avant de reprendre
l'entreprise familiale il y a 20 ans
Hélène était designer elle apporte
depuis sa touche artistique de par ma
formation j'ai amené un autre regard sur
le travail du chocolat que j'ai vraiment
considéré comme un matériau moi dans ma
formation j'ai appris à mettre en forme
du bois du métal du textile du plastique
et j'ai appliqué ça au chocolat par
exemple ici on ne recherche pas la
brillance du chocolat ou encore de
grandes sculptures pour chaque nouvelle
collection Hélène réunit son équipe pour
trois jours de création en laboratoire
autour d'un thème on teste et en innove
les techniques qui nous sont propres
c'est vraiment le fait de pouvoir
réaliser les moules nous-mêmes nous
avons une thermoformeuse et nous
fabriquons nos formes donc ça nous
permet vraiment de sortir du petit
Mickey que l'on retrouve dans toutes les
vitrines et puis aussi le travail de
matière de travail de texture de
peinture qui qui n'est pas du tout
développée dans le monde tradition nel
du chocolat ici par exemple le chocolat
était thermoformé sur de vraies feuilles
de chou là ce sont des instruments de
musique qui ont été repensés on peut
voir ça donc du coup dans votre atelier
à l'étage oui venez on va voir ça de
plus près
alors finalement dans cette chocolaterie
il y a beaucoup d'originalité dans les
créations mais la fabrication reste
traditionnelle oui c'est ça on va créer
des formes nouvelles en moulage en
fabriquant les moules nous-mêmes mais
après la technique de moulage et la
technique vraiment traditionnelle
artisanale c'est-à-dire qu'on part d'un
chocolat à 72% de cacao donc nous le
chocolat qu'on utilise ici c'est un
chocolat un mélange d'Équateur de Sao
Tomé et de Java qui permet d'équilibrer
les saveurs entre les différentes
provenances le chocolat vient d'une
entreprise yvinoise bien connue des
professionnels la chocolaterie du Pecq
après avoir subi une courbe de
température le chocolat est maintenu à
33 degrés dans ses cuves le moulage se
fait en deux étapes une première couche
de chocolat qu'on passe au pinceau dans
le moule et ensuite une deuxième couche
là on voit Flavien qui fait la deuxième
couche en coulée
donc on remplit le moule on le vide
avec un peu d'expérience il reste juste
l'épaisseur désiré
ensuite on le met à refroidir il
refroidit à température ambiante et en
prenant le chocolat va se rétracter et
va se décoller tout seul du moule
ensuite le démoulage
en général on aime bien peindre rajouter
de la couleur et donc il va y avoir une
étape de décor donc là on travaille à
partir de pigment alimentaire qu'on va
diluer soit dans l'alcool soit dans le
beurre de cacao suivant les rendus qu'on
souhaite avoir et on va faire une
finition
on va on va peindre les petites tortues
les petites grenouilles qui vont venir
en élément de finition sur la sur ces
galets ici on voit des moules un peu
différents ce n'est pas des moules en
plastique on pouvait le voir tout à
l'heure alors là ce sont des petits
moules qui sont réalisés en pâte
dentaire ce qu'on fait le chef dentiste
la pâte dentaire l'intérêt c'est
alimentaire et puis ça prend très vite
avec ça on peut vraiment faire des
petits moules rapidement et pour les
petites formes ça c'est pratique un
moulage d'appoint assez atypique dans
une chocolaterie l'idée leur vient d'un
de leurs clients dentiste de profession
donc une autre chocolatière qui peint
toujours avec des pigments là claire
elle c'est une chocolatière
toute fraîchement chocolatière en fait
c'est une artiste peintre qui a fait une
formation
beaux-arts et puis qui s'est spécialisé
dans le chocolat avec nous l'année
dernière il y a pas son cap pour
apprendre à manipuler le chocolat mais
en fait dans l'équipe il y a des
chocolatiers qui font vraiment le
travail de moulage du chocolat et puis
là on est trois à avoir plutôt une
formation artistique et on vient plus
sur le travail de finition de peinture
de décor et donc c'est ces postes là
finalement qui peuvent apporter des
créations des propositions qui c'est en
fait le fait de venir d'un autre milieu
que le milieu chocolatier fait que on a
une autre approche une autre esthétique
une autre façon d'aborder le matériau
donc qui amène une esthétique différente
donc là par exemple à réaliser 7h une
journée pour le faire a réalisé d'après
une photo l'illustration sur l'offre
donc tout en peinture à la main en
dessin
donc par ici c'est la partie du
laboratoire on prépare les intérieurs
des chocolats fourrés en ce moment c'est
les petits up pralinés pour le
garnissage des objets de Pâques donc
pour les petits œufs pralinés on fait
une petite coque en moulage
parce qu'on cherche à avoir une petite
coque très fine
et ensuite il y a le garnissage en
praliné donc le praliné que l'on utilise
pour garnir les petits œufs pralinés
c'est un mélange noisette grillées
amandes grillées sucre cuit pourrailler
ensemble on obtient une pâte très
visqueux dans laquelle on rajoute 20 %
de chocolat noir et c'est ce mélange qui
va nous permettre de garnir les petits
au praliné donc là vous garnissez et
ensuite il y aura l'assemblage on va
voir Fabien qui va faire ça
ça sent très bon en tout cas
du coup comment vous êtes vous organisé
pour ressortir les 40 créations les 40
dernières années dans le fond des
placards dans le fond des tiroirs il y a
pas mal de choses aussi les premières
années il a fallu se souvenir mais
heureusement les chocolatiers qui sont
avec nous sont des gens qui sont là
depuis longtemps et puis qui avaient
quand même le souvenir de cette première
création
les parents d'Hélène ont également du
fouillé dans leur mémoire pour
rationaliser la production il a fallu
s'organiser une collection à la fois et
pour chacune d'entre elles de son pièces
créées à quelques jours de Pâques la
chocolaterie s'adapte aujourd'hui à la
demande pour affiner l'offre 40 ans
d'existence 40 ans de création et cela
devrait perdurer car l'arrivée du design
culinaire portée par Hélène Colas ouvre
de nouvelles perspectives très présents
depuis une dizaine d'années dans le
milieu de la gastronomie se mélangent
entre monde artistique et monde
alimentaire prend de l'ampleur et
atteint même aujourd'hui l'industrie
alimentaire du beau et du beau
et c'est la fin de ce fil écho merci de
nous avoir suivis on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine même format très bonne
soirée